ne vous laissez donc pas impressionné
par les manoeuvres de ceux qui veulent
refermer les portes des bureaux de vote
non nous allons les maintenir largement
couverts que vous ne se réveille en
fonction des derniers sondages pour
savoir ce qui avantage qui je veux dire
juste une chose il s'agit pas que ça
serve de prétexte pour contester le
résultat final d'aller comme ça j'espère
que ce sera pas ça parce qu'alors là ce
serait pire que tout je ne cherche pas
la bénédiction du petit paris mondain
je cherche la résurrection du peuple de
france voilà la différence entre eux et
non du coup les uns de mou qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
franchement je respecte pas dans la
situation dans laquelle je suis fou je
sois bien avec tout le monde mais pas la
manière dont l'élection se profile c'est
on vote pas pour quelque chose
on vote contre quelqu'un parle des
femmes
quand j'ai un boulot énorme oui entre
autres vous êtes mis en examen je cite
pour recel de favoritisme et
détournement de fonds publics
on reviendra dans un incendie a ajouté
que je suis descendant en ligne directe
de gilles de rais et jack l'éventreur
elle vous aime pour vous profondément
pour les deux paires chlorée je suis
désolé bon c'est une histoire ordinaire
il ya soixante mille peu par en france
qui ont des enfants prématurés
et c'est toujours difficile voir s'il
n'y avait pas de discussions sur cette
candidature
tout le monde soutiendrait françois
hollande avec des réussites avec un
enthousiasme avec de l'espoir
donc si vous avez ns hymers savez quoi
je vais venir avec vous faites cas il
nous fait manger clamé par ses
supporters hier soir à new york
donald trump effectué sa première sortie
depuis le scandale de ses propos
sexistes révélé dans une vidéo
je suis automatiquement attirés par les
belles femmes je les embrasse tout de
suite c'est comme un aimant les embrasse
n'attend pas quand on est une star elle
nous laisse faire on fait tout ce qu'on
veut l'amérique blanche des classes et
qui se sent devenir minoritaires souffre
et elle ne mérite pas le mépris dont la
câble l'intelligentia et le showbizz aux
états unis vrai peut-être vu aussi la
petite pastille robert de niro
franck et the dog match didier j'ai fait
des choses que je regrette les mots
publie aujourd'hui datent depuis dix ans
et ce en fait partie je trouve que le
jardin c'est politique c'est ce que
disait me louis quand ils se trouvent